[Música]
[Aplausos]
las disparidades de género tienen su
origen en la desigualdad y en el acceso
restringido a los recursos económicos
siendo la desigualdad la principal causa
y efecto del hambre y la pobreza
estudios han demostrado que cuando
ponemos más recursos económicos en manos
de las mujeres la nutrición infantil la
educación y la salud mejoran en el
núcleo familiar sin embargo a nivel
mundial las mujeres ganan 52 centavos
menos por cada dólar que ganan los
hombres en condiciones similares es por
esto que la organización naciones
unidas- empodera a la mujer a través de
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
viviendo esta realidad a diario y como
madre de una niña querer ser parte de la
solución
me ha hecho convertirme en una
voluntaria ser optimista ser optimista
international es una organización
mundial de mujeres voluntarias de
diversos orígenes y perspectivas cuya
labor es la de empoderar a la mujer y
transformar su vida y su estatus a
través de la educación y el
empoderamiento económico
desde 1972 nuestros programas globales
sueños han transformado e impactado la
vida positivamente de mujeres y niñas
específicamente de 60.000 mujeres
alrededor del mundo
hoy día nuestro programa vive tus sueños
brinda becas y capacitaciones para que
mujeres con desafíos puedan lograr su
potencial pleno
y nuestro programa sueña lo puedes
lograrlo
permite que niñas obtengan las
herramientas que les permitan ser mucho
más empoderadas en este mundo y se
desarrollen personal y profesionalmente
en los últimos cuatro años han
participado más de 55 mil niñas
rompiendo así ciclos de pobreza de
violencia
y para nosotros es un orgullo ser parte
de una organización que tiene una
presencia permanente en la organización
de naciones unidas abogando y luchando
por la igualdad y los derechos humanos
de las mujeres el día de hoy estoy aquí
para invitarlos a que se unan para que
sean responsables y partes de crear un
mundo sostenible donde la paridad de
género sea una realidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]